foreign  [Music]  foreign  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  another  one  oh shit  fantastic  great features  he got me good dog he got him in the  face  oh I'm bleeding  yeah I'm good  he swung back and got me all right  well it didn't take effect  all right  okay  [Music]  our cars are still a sexy man  fine  it's a break  again  [Applause]  second soundtrack  I'm good  [Music]  foreign  start  all right  sir you get stopped  speaking of his location  hey  foreign  hits  and he didn't they didn't do nothing  [Music]  running North Carolina  football field  s  I'm pissed off for anything hey he got  me good I'm bleeding pretty good  my fucking cars are still at six in  Maine  somebody wanted to grow  foreign  yeah I just  dread already hit him didn't take it  back  let him get a little distance was gonna  try again  I hit it yeah and took a step towards  him he's gonna grab him he swung back  around  [Music]  somebody  supposedly cell phone  foreign  another